however happy you are when you come to
another country the cultures difference
I thought they spoke English and yet
when I first came I couldn't understand
a lot of what was said so if it isn't
your language at all I feel for those
people greatly because it must be very
isolating
I felt that I have to I had to prove
myself to the people here then I'm worth
something you're trying to fit in but
you lose your identity and that's what I
did and it took years and years for me
to sort out who I was again you know
when I was applying for jobs in dairy
farming and as a manager you know oh I'm
always struggling uphill if I'm
competing with other Kiwi farm managers
for the job if you know what I mean in
the first two years were exceptionally
hard I'm a very social creature so
trying to fit in trying to make friends
finding a job that took me a really long
time unfortunately there are some biases
around South Africans and the workplace
you had to work really really hard to
create relationships and but their trust
so they're people we're willing to work
with you and willing to share
information and and willing to to adopt
you into the work because you can say
[Music]